I have been watching you you don't have  to remember I saw someone down there  he wasn't human he's a known terrorist  and he's killed again  they didn't just kill them I hacked into  their minds is everywhere I know where I  will find him  and I will kill him  [Music]  you never talk about your past not  remember much whose fragments there was  an attack you were dying we saved you  and now you save others everything they  told you was a lie you had a family  remember that  but I  what a beauty you are  what do you want for me  they did not save your life they stole  it  how many were there before me  she was supposed to have a clean brain  i order you to terminate  major  they created me but they cannot control  me  [Music]  this is Major I'm on site mmm